our subject for this evening the danger
of worship what did i say
the danger of worship
let not your heart be troubled
you believe in god
believe also in me
in my father's house are many mansions
if it were not so i would have told you
i go to prepare a place for you and if i
go and prepare a place for you i will
come again and receive you unto myself
that where i am
there ye may be also
and whether i go ye know and the way he
know thomas saith unto him lord we know
not wither thou goest and how can we
know the way
jesus have unto him i am the way the
truth and the life
no man cometh unto the father
but by me
god is good
and all the time
how has your day been up to this point
fine
well we thank god for that i have the
same testimony i have no complaints
whatsoever i can hardly believe i felt a
little hot today
considering the temperature in my home
state of michigan right now somewhere in
the 20s
it's it makes no sense to me to feel
warm in february
but i enjoy the heat very much
in a few days i will return to the deep
freeze
but i always tell god
i thank you i'm alive to feel cold or to
feel hot i always tell my congregations
when i'm shoveling snow and you don't
shovel snow in this part of the world
very much
when you're shoveling a foot of snow and
it's wet it's heavy
and i pray as i shovel snow literally
pray
and i thank god father i thank you
i have the strength that's how i shovel
snow
to keep my sanity i thank god
i have the strength
i literally do that to shovel snow and i
said father i prefer to be doing this
than to be lying on a hospital bed so in
everything give thanks for this is the
will of god
in christ jesus concerning you
anyone with us tonight for the very
first time raise your hand first time
ah please tell us your name
karen reeves is that r-e-e-o-r-e-a
r-e-a karen reeves
sister reeves where are you from
bermuda's a good place i've been there
several times i call it the pink
paradise
i have some precious friends in bermuda
warren smith and his wife tammy from
st george's i think church
and then
okay
no tammy
yes warren and tammy and then there's um
the bins
the father passed recently
the daughter quinnell and her husband
stephen
and a few a few other friends i have on
that lovely little island
well nice to have you
and the lord bless you in all kinds of
unexpected ways say amen for sister
reeves
from the pink paradise called bermuda
anybody else with us for the very first
time
have i seen you before
all right is this your first visit
oh nice to have you
god bless you
we will not try to guess your name will
you tell us what it is
suspense
nice to have you where are you from
that's fine yes
philadelphia
god bless philadelphia the city of
brotherly love thank you for coming
may the lord place his hand of mercy
upon your life and never remove it
until he ushers you into his kingdom say
amen for suspense
all right now for those of you who've
come night after night thank you so much
for your faithful attendance god is
pleased i'm quite sure and i'm delighted
to have you our subject for this evening
the danger of worship what did i say
the danger of worship
before i get into that please make sure
your
gadgets are turned off so nothing
interrupts us as we worship the living
god
god loves reverence and you have been
giving him that and so i thank you very
much
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth i make the request all
the time and every time i make it i am
serious ask god
to tell me what to say jeremiah chapter
1 verse 9 then the lord put forth his
hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth
and favor number three think as you
listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together saith the lord let us
pray
our father and our god we come to you
again as we have come every evening and
every afternoon
we cannot come to you too often
we come because your word says come unto
me only that labor and a heavy laden
we come because your word says let us
come boldly to the throne of grace
and so we come
in the name of jesus
someone equal with yourself
that person who said i am the
resurrection and the life
it was he who said
let there be light
in his name we come we ask immediately
if we've sinned against you forgive us
dear god please
give us hatred for sin
and a restless love for righteousness
put your words in my mouth dear god
grant to me the meekness and humility of
christ
put your ideas in my mind
for those listening if anyone is sick be
merciful to that person god and bring
healing or great great relief
particularly in cases of covet 19.
grant that person or those persons total
relief i pray
bless this country bless the leadership
remind the leadership somehow their god
that righteousness exalted the nation
bless the country bermuda where sister
reeves is from
father
i commit this service to your glory use
me the god i pray in jesus name
amen
what's our subject
the danger of worship 637 i release you
by as soon as i can
genesis chapter 4 let's read from verse
genesis 4 reading from verse 1 i read
from the king james version of the bible
genesis means the beginning
chapter four
reading from verse one
and adam knew eve his wife and she
conceived and bear cain and said i have
gotten a man from the lord
and she again bear his brother abel and
abel was a keeper of sheep but cain was
a tiller of the ground
and in process of time it came to pass
that cain brought of the fruit of the
ground an offering unto the lord an abel
he also brought of the firstlings of his
flock and of the fat thereof and the
lord had respect unto abel and to his
offering but under cain and to his
offering he had not respect and cain was
very rough and his countenance fell
let's pause right there
two men came to worship
cain
and abel
one brought a lamb
that could shed blood
one brought fruits
that do not bleed
the bible says without shedding of blood
finish it for me there is no remission
this did not begin in the days of the
book of hebrews it began from the very
moment adam's sin that's why god removed
the aprons of leaves because leaves do
not bleed and replace them with courts
of skins from animals in the garden that
adam himself had to kill because it is
the sinner that kills the animal
cain knew
he had to bring an animal
by so doing he was he would demonstrate
symbolize that he trusted someone else
for his salvation that being christ
abel brought an animal because abel knew
he could not save himself
abel came trusting god's merits
cain came trusting his own words his own
works
the bible says and the lord had respect
unto abel
and to his offering
but unto cain and to his offering
he had not respect
two opposite reactions
to the same act what was that act
worship
because it happens in a church
does not make it acceptable to god
if obedience is not present
you know there's something in the past
couple decades i guess or more
a habit developed among people of
attaching the word gospel
so you have gospel aerobics
and you have gospel wrath
and you have gospel rock
i don't know if you have gospel murder
a gospel fornication but you attach the
word gospel and that is supposed to make
it acceptable to god
we need more gospel obedience
do what i say
and so god accepted cain and his
offering sorry abel and his offering
rejected cain and his offering i want to
observe he did not simply reject the
offering he rejected the offerer
accepted abel and his offering
accepted
rejected cain and his offering now in
verse 6
the lord said unto cain unto him why are
thou wroth why is thy countenance fallen
if thou doest well
who did well
abel did well that's why he was
accepted
god is very fair
god did not reject cain because cain was
not as handsome as abel cain did not do
what he was required to do god said if
thou doest well shalt thou not be
accepted if you return the tithe will i
not bless you
if thou doest not well sin life at the
door and unto thee shall be his desire
and thou shall rule over him god said
you do as abel did and i a very fair and
balanced god will accept you as verily
as i accepted abel go to hebrews 11
let's read verse 4 subject danger of
worship
hebrews 11
reading verse 4.
let me remind you again when i go too
fast just say slow down preacher
and i will slow down immediately
for a few minutes
so you'll have to tell me over and over
i'm hard headed when it comes to
remembering to slow down what book did i
say
what chapter
what verse
by faith abel offered unto god a more
excellent sacrifice than cain
by which she obtained witness that he
was what
righteous
now
let's combine all let's add hebrews 11 4
to genesis 4
verse 7 verse 6 verses 6 and 7
in six and seven seven god said to cain
if thou doest well
shalt thou not be accepted six if thou
doest not well sin life at the door and
unto thee shall be his desire and thou
shall rule over him king did not do
what was right in the sight of god he
did not do it
righteousness is not only what you think
righteousness is also what you
do
there is a doing involved in living an
upright life there is a doing involved
in obeying god it is not simply a state
of mind which is essential
but it is actually the practice of
principle the doing
one of our favorite verses is all
scripture is given by inspiration of god
and is profitable for doctrine for
reproof for correction for instruction
in righteousness here is how you behave
righteously
instruction people can be taught how to
behave righteously
in addition to having the righteous
mindset by having christ within you now
if thou
doest well do what you want to do
and so in verse 4
of hebrews 11 by faith which means that
abel that cain's offering was brought
how
no faith
the bible says faith cometh by hearing
and hearing come on finish it for me by
the word of god
obedience
there is no faith without obedience
by faith abel offered unto god a more
excellent sacrifice than cain by which
he obtained witness that he was
righteous now who was the eyewitness to
the righteous behavior of abel
god
that hasn't changed
when we worship god in obedience to his
requirements he becomes a personal
witness to our righteous behavior
by which he obtained witness that he was
righteous god testifying of his gifts
what a remarkable thing to consider that
god himself shows up to witness on your
behalf and on mine
two men
came to worship
god accepted one
did not accept the other because one
worship based on thus saith the lord the
other worship based on whatever his
feelings were his traditions were both
actions look similar
but one was based by obedience the other
based on self-will my listening friend
the fact that you come to worship
does not mean god accepts it if
obedience is absent because god prefers
obedience to sacrifice
let's leave brothers cain and abel for a
while
let's go to leviticus chapter 16.
leviticus 16
we'll read verse one
book number three and the key word for
leviticus is
holiness that's the thematic word
holiness
and the lord speak unto moses that's
leviticus 16 verse 1
after the death of this two sons of
aaron when they offered before the lord
and
died
name them
nadab
and abihu
you read the story in leviticus 10. they
brought strange fire and the bible says
they went out fire from god and devoured
them and they died before the lord
leviticus 10 verse 2. they offered
strange fire according to verse the end
of verse 1 of leviticus 10 which god
commanded
not if he did not command that he
commanded something else and i like the
word command they worship contrary to
god's command regarding the form of
worship you could not bring strange fire
before god nadab and abide who sons of
levi priests
they brought strange fire and god took
their lives but they came to worship
what's our subject
the danger
of worship
that danger is worship based on
disobedience
i do not mean ignorance i said
to mark chapter seven
mark seven
we read from verse six
mark chapter seven
reading from verse six
that was my speed
okay
one handsome member said good
so i feel comforted
what book did i say mark what chapter
seven reading from one verse six let me
pray holy father in heaven please lord
tighten your grip on all that is me all
that's required to deliver this message
in jesus name i pray amen
he answered and said unto them well hath
isis prophesied as the hypocrites as it
is written read with me now this people
how honor with me how with their lips
but their hearts are far from me read
the next verse carefully slowly and
microscopically come on
how be it in vain do they worship me
teaching for doctrines the commandments
of men now
what is vain
useless
but there's another there's a word in
that verse in vain
do they what
worship
every weekend all over this country
there are people worshiping god
in vain
listen to why christ said it's in vain
in vain do they worship me teaching for
doctrine the commandments of men
read the next verse for me verse eight
what does that say four
aside uh-huh the commandments of god ye
hold to the what traditions of
people can't jesus this is not accident
christ says you deliberately set aside
my commandments in order to accommodate
your tradition like the washing of pots
and pans and many other such things they
do
and he said full well read first night
now and he said unto them what
full well you do what reject the
commandments of god that he may do what
because you can't keep both
are you with me
you can't be right and wrong at the same
time
you can't be sweet and bitter
you've got to reject one
to have the other
go to
second peter chapter 2.
let's read what the bible says about
balaam
here's an example of the bible
bilaam occurs in numbers we have some
information in ii peter almost the end
of the bible
second peter chapter 2 let's read verse
15 referring to false teachers what does
that verse say
which have forsaken come on the right
way keep reading and are going to stress
stop you see what that verse says action
and reaction
that's a physical law but it applies
spiritually which have forsaken the
right way and have gone astray jesus
says full well you reject the
commandment of god that you may hold
your own tradition one action has a
reaction you cannot do both you forsake
the right way you go your own way you
reject god's command you have your
tradition
all in the context of worship
go with me
to
exodus 32.
exodus 32
i hope someone has said lord
put your words in that man's mouth
exodus 32.
in verse one
are you there
and when the people saw that moses
delayed to come down out of the mount
the people gathered themselves together
unto aaron and said up make us gods
which can do up
go before us they want to go back to
egypt for as for this moses the man that
brought us up out of the land of egypt
we what not what is become of him he had
been in the mount 40 days for the nice
day they didn't see him for several
almost seven weeks
we need to go back
make us gods
and aaron said unto them break off the
golden earrings which are in the ears of
your wives of your sons and of your
daughters and bring them unto me and all
the people break off the golden earrings
which were in their ears and gave them
unto aaron
and receive them their hand and freshen
it with a grieving tool after he had
made it a molten calf and they said read
with me now
these be thy gods or israel which
brought thee up out of the land of egypt
this is your god
verse 5
and when aaron saw it who is aaron
the high priest
what position did the high priest hold
he was the leader of the spiritual lives
of the people
it was moses
then aaron are you with me the second
highest office of authority for god's
people aaron the bible says when aaron
saw it he built an altar before it and
aaron made proclamation and said what
finished verse 5 tomorrow is a feast to
the lord
let's put that in a different version
tomorrow we will offer god idol worship
it was offered to god
now
we know that god was about to destroy
the israelites
and moses jumped between god and the
israelites
so he told god if you destroy them
destroy me
and god loved that because he was like
christ you see christ between the sinner
and god
tomorrow
is a feast
to the lord
the fact that it's done in a church
does not make it safe because it was the
church that said crucify him
it was a church that killed
millions of people over the past
centuries because they wanted to live
their lives how by thus it was a church
let me be blunt and bold with the
catholic church
religious organizations carry out
greater atrocities than secular ones it
seems
tomorrow is the feast of the lord verse
6 of deuteronomy exodus 32
and what
and they rose early on the mortar and
offered burnt offerings and brought to
our peace offerings and the people sat
down to eat and drink and rose up to
play and the lord said unto moses go
get thee down for thy people wish that
brought us out of up out of egypt have
done what corrupted themselves now what
were they doing
worshipping how does god describe it
corruption
they've corrupted themselves this is the
same hebrew word used in genesis 6 the
word the earth the world where the earth
was corrupt before god and the world was
full of violence and god looked upon the
earth genesis 6 12 and behold it was
corrupt for all flesh had corrupted his
way same word it was a condition a
microscopic condition of the macroscopic
situation that led to the flood
for the time of the flood a whole world
was destroyed
in this instance a nation was about to
be destroyed but for one man who stepped
in
they have corrupted themselves
they have gone away quickly out of the
way which i have commanded them they've
made them a molten calf and have
worshiped him and offered there unto
and said these were thy gods or israel
which have brought thee up out of the
land of egypt and lord said unto moses
verse 9 i have seen this people finish
the verse
and behold it is a what stiff what is
stiff naked
stubborn i will do things my way
despite a very clear
thus come on save the lord
stiffness
god said i god's assessments are always
right i have seen have examined i've
looked i've obsessed i've evaluated they
are stiffness now
let me alone says god this is if moses
had held him that's the way i see it and
god says let me go
that my wrath may wax hot against them
and that i may consume them and i will
make of thee a great nation
god wasn't joking god was angry
so we know god is a personal being we
don't understand exactly how he exists
jesus said the spirit hath not flesh and
bones of god
but jesus said he has a shame
but we know however he exists he gets
angry he's pleased he's happy he blesses
he punishes he's a personal being
and he wants to destroy this light and
start fresh with moses
and moses besought the lord his god and
said lord why doth thy wrath wax hot
against thy people which thou hast
brought forth out of the land of egypt
wherefore should egyptians speak and say
for mischief did he bring them out to
slay them upon the mountains and to
consume them from the face of the earth
that's moses appealing to god don't let
the egyptians speak badly you will look
bad if you do that
that's an interesting appeal because god
always works for his glory
it's for his glory
and that would not have been for his
glory moses said the egyptians will talk
badly about you
and god turned away his wrath
what am i trying to tell you
worship conducted in disobedience to
god's plainly stated word is not
accepted by god
now let's go to first corinthians 10.
listen to paul speaking of this event
and giving us a warning a warning first
corinthians 10 we'll read from verse one
our subject what
the end of worship
and what's that danger worship without
obedience
first corinthians 10 do you have that
let me pray father
slow me down
speak through me still
give me simple language
in jesus name i pray amen
moreover brethren i would not that you
should be ignorant how that all our
fathers were under the cloud and all
passed through the sea and were all
baptized unto moses in the cloud and in
the sea and it all eat the same
spiritual meat and they'd all drink the
same spiritual drink for the drank of
that spiritual rock that followed them
finished the verse and that rock was
christ but with many of them god was not
well pleased for they were overthrown in
the wilderness or destroyed now these
things are examples to the intent we
should not lust after evil things as
they also lusted let's reread verse 6.
there's an interesting word there
i'll give you the greek
read six with me now
these things were our
example the kingdom says and sample same
thing truthy intent come on
we should not lust or desire
evil things as they did now
the word therefore example or ensemble
is tupos the greek
which is the same word for type are you
with me
a type has an antitype
so the lamb in the old testament was the
type
what was the antitype of that lamb jesus
christ himself very good okay
paul is telling his people and telling
us
what they did
should serve as a type
so that you don't do the same thing
to the intent we should not lust the
bible these are examples but not to
follow to avoid
read verse seven
neither
be idolaters as were some of them as it
is written the people sat down to eat
and drink and rose up to play we read
that in verse 6 exodus 32 that's what
they did paul is saying you see that
don't do that
now
let's
cast our minds back to that sad
catastrophic event
and uh let's identify
the two obvious commands that were
violated what were they
in worship in the golden calf what two
commands were violated directly
don't worship idols of course the idol
is your god so also command with one
have no gods before me you see they said
make us gods to take us back to each
that's what they said
those were the gods
they worship idols they made them
that violation came from which table of
the law
come on come on table one
what is that table distinctive what's
distinctive about that table
it shows love for god
are you with me
love for god
all right
let's go to daniel
daniel 3.
you're ready for verse 4
then and herald cried aloud to you it is
what
commanded
all people nations and languages that at
what time you hear the sound of the
cornet flute flute harps sample solitary
dulcimer all kinds of music he fall down
and worship what the golden image which
nebuchadnezzar the king have set up
what's the key word in there
worship
but who set up the thing to be
worshipped
they began
what was the thing to be worshipped an
idol
what commandment violated
one and two
from the table that expresses love and
faithfulness to god
another key word in verse 4
commanded
now question for you
is there a literal babylon today
but is there a literal spiritual babylon
that sounds confusing a literal is there
really a spiritual babylon yes
revelation talks much about this babylon
which is simply description of a power
that will exist and does exist now in
the end time and his full power has not
yet been exercised
let's go learn what this babylon power
will do
let's go to revelation 13.
revelation 13.
let's read from verse 1
is 702.
i'll let you go
when i'm done
revelation 13 let's read from verse one
that's not a threat i'll be finished
before 7 30.
don't worry
are you there
and i stood up on the sand of the sea
and saw a beast rise up out of the sea
having seven heads and ten horns and
upon his arms come on ten crowns upon
his head what name of blasphemy the
beast which i saw was like unto a
leopard and his feet was the feet of a
bear and his mouth as a mouth of the
lion and the dragon gave him his power
and his seat and great authority now in
bible prophecy what does a beast
represent
a kingdom a power whether political or
religious it's a power it's a system
that exercises power over people
and the dragon gave him his power and
his seat and great authority
in bible in the bible who's the dragon
satan yes very very obvious revelation
12 9 revelation 20 verse 2.
and i saw one of his heads verse 3 as it
were wounded to death and his deadly
wound was healed and all the world
wandered after the beast verse four and
they worshipped the dragon which gave
power unto the beast now this is a
repetition of verse two the dragon gave
him his power his seed his authority
it's repeated in four and they
worshipped the dragon which gave power
unto the beast and they worship the
beast saying who is like unto the beast
who is able to make war with him let me
pause
the beast is a system
religious system that also exercises
political authority it's a strange beast
and for hundreds of years
the reformers martin luther you name
them
isaac newton all reformers virtually
have identified that beast as the papal
system
i'm not trying to be harsh i'm just
telling you historically the conclusions
bible scholars have come to not send the
advocates only bible scholars have come
to the conclusion studying the
prophecies this beast is the papal
system
but there's something very embarrassing
in verse 4 of revelation 13 see if you
can identify read it for me nice and
loud and they worship
uh-huh
can anyone see the devil
no you can't say the devil can you see
god no
how do they worship the dragon
by worshiping the beast
ah father be with me
there are millions of people worshiping
the devil
without seeing the devil or believing
they're worshiping the devil
and they worship the dragon which but no
one sees the devil people don't even
acknowledge the presence of the devil i
mean in our legal system we have acts of
god we don't have acts of satan
are you with me a flood is an act of god
a hurricane a landslide an avalanche or
a tornado or whatever a tsunami acts of
god
you know acts of the devil
if you order something from amazon prime
is supposed to arrive the next day and
then there's an earthquake and the whole
amazon warehouse goes down you can't sue
amazon for not delivering they can argue
an act of god
you know acts of satan
so generally people think the devil
doesn't exist and that suits him just
fine
they worship the dragon which gave power
unto the beast when someone kneels to an
idol that idol is a piece of stone or
wood
the person is really kneeling before
whom
satan
when eve came to adam after she took of
the fruit
what did she go to adam to do
come on
to get him to do what
give another word
disobey she went to
she went to encourage your husband to
disobey now was she an agent of god
come on talk to me she was an agent of
satan
in that time
of course she took the covering of skin
so she repented she was an agent of
satan
you don't believe me listen to jesus
when peter said be it far from the lord
this shall not be unto thee i will not
let you go to jerusalem jesus turned and
said what
get it behind me satan
in that brief moment peter was an agent
come on talk to me of satan and jesus
acknowledged that notice i said in that
rich woman
you don't need a long time to be an
agent to save
but peter thought he was doing christ a
favor
there are people worshiping the devil
and god's heart is broken they are not
aware of it but when you worship and
disobedience to god you're not
worshiping god
intention is not enough
good intentions not enough thus saith
the lord
that's why god told cain if you do
what's right
i'll accept you
if you don't you're rejected
they worship the dragon
whis gave power to the beast and they
worship the beast saying who is like
unto the beast who is able to make war
with now notice the power the beast has
go to verse 15 of revelation 13 we're
talking about a power that exists today
revelation chapter 13 verse 15 was that
say and he had power to give life to the
image of the beast and that the image of
the beast should both speak and cause
that as many as would not worship the
image of the beast come on should be
killed now how does the image how does
this power cause people to do that
how does a nation cause people to do one
thing or another
what side of the street do you drive
what power caused you to do that
allah
caused you to drive on the right side of
the street
a law caused you to attach license plate
if you break that law you find a law
tells you 55 miles per hour or 35 or 70
years in my state a law
and if it's violated there's a penalty
and so that power that spiritual
political power will cause people to
worship the beast at on pain of death
for those who disobey what i'm saying to
you is we will soon come to the time
when in this country and around the
world a certain kind of worship will be
enforced by law
and penalty for disobedience will be
death as it was in the days of the three
hebrew boys in babylon and daniel in
middle persia
because those things were types because
jesus says as it was in the days of noah
well as it was in the days of daniel
now
you may say well there are ten
commandments which one will they attack
in the united states almost 30 states
have
blue laws
almost i don't think tennessee has
almost 30 states clear have blue laws
many european countries have blue laws
these laws restrict what you can do on a
certain day of the week what day is that
sunday
a day
not recognized as a day of worship in
the bible
not recognized at all
and sunday keeping churches have said
that in the official literature that the
sabbath of the bible is saturday the
seventh day these blue laws protect
sunday
but god's day in the bible is which day
the seventh-day sabbath
when you're protecting sunday or
wednesday
god will say to you what he said to cain
if thou dost well
shalt thou not be accepted
if thou doest not well send life at the
door and i'm not talking about genuine
ignorance because genuine ignorance mean
i don't know i had no way of knowing
those two things comprise genuine
ignorance
there's coming a time
when
sunday will be regarded as the legal day
of worship
and all the blue laws are already in
place to make that process fairly
painless
or simple to enact
when that happens
what will you do
don't tell me
will you and i have the courage to say
we ought to obey god finish the first
for me rather than men where is that
found acts 5
we ought to obey god
even at the loss of what
life and this is no joke
we read fox's book of martyrs how people
died they were burned alive eaten by
animals we read those things and we say
what strong people they were we don't
realize the same thing may befall us
let me tell you something about human
nature
there's a verse in the bible which says
the heart is deceitful above all things
and desperately what wicked
who can know it
which means
no human being can fully understand the
depth to which a human being can stink
in criminal behavior and destructive
behavior not even the person himself the
heart is deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked who can know it only
god
we see an example of that when they said
crucify him crucify him now if people
try to get their hands on god and kill
him what will they not do to god's
people
the danger
of worship
jesus said
in vain do they worship me
teaching for doctrine
i am
god who was it who said it was a brother
my good brother here he'd like he
wouldn't like to be god it must be hard
being god someone said that
i wouldn't like to be god for five
minutes
too much pain
let me
explain give me some holidays that we
observe
who
fourth of july
christmas
thanksgiving
who
mother's day don't leave the fathers out
father's day sweetest day i don't know
who that targets but sweetest day come
on what else
who
easter
veterans day
halloween
what else
birthdays
valentine's valentine's day gets two
votes okay valentine's day
let me tell you something
of all the special days that you can
observe
god has only asked for one
tell me that one
the servant
and he doesn't get it
so we come to him and say
well what about valentine's day no
father what about easter no
what about
christmas
no
what about halloween so we can dress up
which one do you want
the one in the bible
the seventh-day sabbath that's what i
want
there's coming a time in this country
this world
it'll start in this country
when sunday observance will be required
by law the pope in 1998 diaz domini
that's the name of the his people
encyclical
uh not who was the hero was the pope in
98 um john paul the second i think he
called
for people to approach their legislators
to make sunday a legal day of worship
the catholic church has been trying for
for quite a while to get that done in
europe
and they'll succeed
the bible says in second timothy chapter
3 verse 3
but evil men and seducers shall wax
worse and worse
deceiving and being deceived the love of
many shall wax cold
will succeed
and it'll spread
if god
almost destroyed the israelites
for violating commandments more than two
if god destroyed nida by who
for
disobeying him and not bringing proper
fire
if god disregarded cain for not bringing
the proper worship the proper way
how does god react when we disregard the
sabbath
i'll tell you why i say that of all the
ten commandments the central commandment
is the sabbath commandment
you say well you say that because you're
out of this no you look at it
you look at all the nine commandments
they don't tell you who god is
they don't
command three um thou shalt not take the
law of the name of the lord i got into
him but who's the law thy god you don't
know
commandment one thou shalt have no other
gods but who is you don't know
commandment two that shall not make it
for i the lord thy god i'm a jealous god
you don't know commandment five honor
thy father thy mother that thy days may
be long upon the land which allah thy
god who is he commandment for the one
who made come on talk to me heaven and
earth who is that the creator now if you
made heaven he made earth and everything
in it he has a right
commandment for establishes god's right
to rule why because i made the heaven
and the earth and everything in it
when six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in them is
everything in the earth in heaven and
rest of the seventh day that commandment
establishes the supremacy of god the
area of his of his control his title who
he is and the reason why he deserves our
worship
thou art worthy lord to receive glory
and honor and power for thou has created
all things revelation 4 11 the
fundamental reason why we worship god is
because he's the creator
not just the savior
because if there'd been no sin he would
still have been the creator
in the new world there'll be no sin no
savior there'll still be a creator
because as long as there's a heaven and
earth you need a creator to keep them
running
i'm going too fast you're not rebuking
me as you should
it's your beautiful fault let me slow
down
christ as
savior that became necessary because of
sin
are you with me
you sure you're with me if adam had not
sinned there would have been no need for
calvary or for christ that no savior
but there has always been come on
creator
and so in uh isaiah 66 23 and it shall
come to pass that from one new moon to
another and from one sabbath to another
shall all flesh come to worship before
me this is describing life in the new
world
the sabbath will be kept
this means the law will still exist
god sends warnings
because he loves us
and he gives us a chance to turn turn
around
change
he came to warren king
he gave cain every opportunity
to change his behavior
what it can do
he killed abel
when christ raised lazarus from the tomb
the pharisees were so enraged this was
evidence that christ was god they tried
to do what
kill lazarus
remove any proof of god's divinity
remove it kill god kill lazarus
god said you do like your brother i'll
receive you he got rid of the brother
but you can't get rid of this
because christ himself is the word
what's our subject
7 19
worship not based on obedience
is offensive to god
let me give you the words of the savior
you love so much
in vain do they worship me
teaching for doctrines
the commandments of men
it goes on to say full well
full well verse night illusion you know
what you're doing says jesus to keep
your tradition you lay aside
i was uh
did i tell you this i was speaking in
detroit many years ago
a lady came to the meeting she accepted
the sabbath truth
and she went to her husband because we
offered 2500 to anyone who could bring
two bible texts one that said the first
day is a holy and two the sabbath has
been changed two takes bring them we
give you 25 and we had the 2 500
nobody came to get it but this lady went
to a husband she said honey the house
needs some repairs
twenty five hundred dollars just about
do it and she told me the story she said
give me the two texts the husband said
yeah she said what he said nothing here
she said give me the two texts he said
there are no texts
what do you think she asked him
why do we do it
you know what he said
i was
born a baptist come on finish it i'll
die of baptism
that's what he said
i was in nigeria
preaching on a university campus smart
people i offered 400 crisp u.s dollars
every student is broke are you following
me
okay
every student needs tuition 400
bring me through text the same too
i said go do your research bring me two
texts the next day i called nobody came
after the service this young man came to
me he said he said elder
uh
i searched i said you find the text he
said no
he said but can i still have the money i
said
i said you can forget that
can i still have the money but he said i
searched there are no such texts
what's our subject
what's that danger
worshiping based on
listen to me
everyone lost
would have chosen to be lost
everyone saved
come on talk to me would have chosen to
be saved how will you choose
what do you choose
to be saved
what does god want from you and me
obedience do
what i say remember
7 22 let me finish quickly remember
exodus 25 verse 8 let me pray father i'm
closing give me something significant to
close with in jesus name amen
go to genesis 6.
genesis 6
this is god telling noah a flood is
coming and get ready
genesis 6 reading from verse 13
and god said unto noah the end of all
flesh has come before me for the earth
is filled with violence through them and
behold i will do what destroy them in
the earth read 14 with me now make thee
an ark of go forwards come on
roon shall i make in the ark and shall
pitch it within and without with pitch
keep reading and this is the fashion
which down shall make it of the length
of the ark shall be 300 cubits the
breadth of it 50 cubits the height of it
30 cubits a window shout thou made to
the ark and in the qubit shout out
finish it above
and the door of the ark shall now set in
the side thereof with lower second and
third story shall now make it stop
are those details god gave moses noah
come on
architectural deity which one of them
could he change
none he had to do what
precisely what god said
god said the length 300 feet he could
not make it 299.
we hate the word straight we think
strict is cruel no strict is a good word
because that's what you want your neural
surgeon to be when he operates on your
brain
okay
we want the doctor to be straight
[Music]
he's working on my brain the eye surgeon
you better be strict
don't watch the nfl while you're working
on my eyes be straight
what about god when god said let them
make me a sanctuary that i might dwell
among them all the details from chapter
25 to chapter 40 of the book of exodus
moses could not change one detail
the danger of worship
worship based on
disobedience
who accepts that worship
satan
not god
there are only two objects of worship
god
and satan
only two
there were two voices in the garden of
eden god
and satan there were two voices when
satan rebelled in heaven god and lucifer
in heaven god lucifer in eden god
lucifer
today
god lucifer satan
choose god
he or she who chooses god
chooses obedience
how many will choose god can i see your
hand
choose god i tell you let's pray father
in heaven
it was a tough sermon perhaps
if i said anything i shouldn't have said
if i was too harsh forgive me that god
but father you know i'll do anything say
anything to see somebody saved
because calvary is proof you did
everything you could
to provide salvation
take my meagre effortless garden through
the ministry of your spirit
improve what i said and apply it again
like a needle of conviction to the
hearts of everyone who listened and who
will listen to this recorded version
father help us to understand hell is no
place to go
and heaven is no place to miss
i open our eyes they're god to see when
we're going astray
break down the jericho walls of
stubbornness that surround us sometimes
in all areas of life that god could be
in a romantic behavior our social
behavior whatever it is sometimes we're
just stubborn
and when people are stubborn you want to
save them sometimes you've got to break
their backs
but father we don't want to put you that
far or push you that far
give us the humility
to accept things your way
because your way
is the way of life
let us choose their god
obedience because in so doing we will
simply be reflecting the lifestyle of
jesus christ who obeyed you
give us a love for your word
the love for your law of righteousness
a love for our savior
as we leave father let the angels escort
us to our homes protect us watch over us
as we sleep may please you to bring us
back tomorrow father do you hear your
words again
i pray from my heart in jesus name
amen
[Music]
you